[Music]
so
[Music]
what is up what is good how you living
how you doing how you feeling connor
rogers i'm gonna be honest i'm not
feeling too great this is gonna be my
michael jordan
flu game if i need you to carry me do
you got me
i got you lefko you're a champ though
for power and through it's gonna be a
good one my man
don't worry everybody i got tested
yesterday i'm covered free i just got a
lot of stuff in my face you know what
else i have
a lot of stuff that we need to talk to
because we are now
21 days away from the nfl draft we are
getting ready to
have that three day festive is it two
days now no three day festival
with my guy connor rogers and some
special guests
what we've been doing uh whether it's
been on the br
app as i'm watching right now gridiron
twitter
and of course be our youtube i pick
conor's brain every week
he tells me different topics that i need
to know we've done quarterbacks we've
done most explosive players
today we are doing most debated
prospects we have this every year i
remember when
derek henry was debated i remember when
dk metcalf
was debated so they always get fun and
we're gonna have a special guest today
mike renner lead draft analyst for pff
connor i know you were on his podcast i
know you respect what he has to say
i'm sure he's gonna have a lot of great
stuff also as well
if you want your comments mentioned on
the show
make sure you do it in the br app i am
in the nfl draft stream right now
and if i see good ones i will read them
as we get ready let's first get right
off the bat connor
with a video comment that means if you
got a video comment you are getting a br
gridiron hoodie so let's see where we're
starting off connor
hey connor and levco this is ryan here
so i had a quick question
as a devout just found think about the
future at two positions wide receiver
and cornerback
so for these prospects who will be the
better fit and wide receiver
elijah moore or rashad bateman and at
cornerback
greg newsom or jc horn thanks keep up
the great work guys
go for it connor i love the question
first off because those are really
interesting debates when you look at the
prospects now for the first one at wide
receiver it's the harder one for me
i think rashad bateman is a first round
player and a better player but in this
situation i'm actually going to go with
elijah moore for the jets because of
what they need they already got
a guy that can make catches in traffic
and corey davis and they hope denzel
mims can be that guy
too so instead you go to elijah moore a
smaller player but
tons of speed 4-3 kind of speed 436 kind
of 40
really good vertical jump at his size we
know he's explosive he can win over
the top he's very twitched up you can
get him going on those jet sweeps as
well that we know mike lafleur in that
offense is going to want to do so
i really like elijah moore in round two
for the jets if that's an option for
them then you look at the corners now
this is where things get a little more
interesting but jc horn is too talented
for me
to not take him over greg newsom when
you look at horn the size
the press coverage ability obviously the
speed and explosiveness but he just
lives in receivers pockets
and that's what he does he makes a play
on the ball over and over again
we know robert sala loves having guys on
the back end with a little bit of
attitude you ever hear richard sherman
there and that
season they made it to the super bowl so
i think jc horn is a great fit
for that defense so elijah moore jc horn
the jets came out of the draft with two
of those guys you'd have to be
really really excited the jets are
completely different franchise now
they've made a trade
but i want to bring in our guests to
break it all down let's bring in mike
renner pff
lead draft analyst i'm very excited
because i really just want to see his
hair
okay it looks good this is a super solid
floetry
if all three of us are on camera i am in
third place
i have never felt this self-conscious
about my flow
mike good to have you here thanks for
having me on it's
uh not quite once was with the length
but it
i feel like it's all right now still uh
i was alluding to before the
sam darnold trade and i know that connor
knows the jets
extremely well i before we get into any
of the app comments and stuff like that
your guy's initial reactions mike you're
first with the trade
of sam darnold to carolina binocular
reaction was no one wants
there the falcons won't trade up with
carolina and the carolina doesn't think
they're going to be able to get up to
that class and it just reeked in my
opinion of desperation you know they
don't want they don't think ted
bridgewater is the guy they obviously
could not lead them on a lot of fourth
quarter comebacks last year couldn't
attack down the football field
so they kind of went the opposite way
with a guy who
has that ability but maybe is not nearly
as accurate underneath maybe doesn't
have
uh the sort of steadiness that you see
from teddy bridgewater over the course
of his career so
to me it was just reeked of desperation
yeah i think when i looked at it you
know i i agree with mike
that there just weren't a lot of dance
partners for the jets right you kind of
got to this point where you heard the
nonsense that hey they might get a first
rounder for darnold months ago
that didn't exist and then as teams find
their options in the off season and the
landing spots start to dwindle
they're looking at it and you're going
man are they even even going to be able
to get a second round pick out of this
it might be a third round pick and they
end up getting
a future second fourth and then a six
this year which is an adequate return
for a player that's really struggled
all three years barring you know how bad
the circumstances around him have been
but
let's talk about the panthers with this
like mike said you look at the situation
it just feels like they were kind of
boxed into a corner with no
options they felt great about they
probably can't move up to four like he
said
and then you start to wonder is anyone
gonna fall to us is anybody gonna be
there after four that we
like maybe they don't like all five
quarterbacks and they felt like
they had to make a move now the reason
they're the one team that can afford
this risk when you look at it because a
lot of guys when they make a move for a
quarterback if it doesn't work out they
get fired in the nfl
matt rule is on a really really long
term deal
they just hired scott federer to be
their gm so he's not going anywhere
it's never the first thing you want to
hear about a deal but if they do fail
with darnold for a year or two and i
don't think he'll be terrible under joe
brady but
not ever gonna be a star then they have
the uh you know the leeway a little bit
to try something else
there are plenty of thoughts right now
it seems as though we're going
quarterback quarterback quarterback one
two three
the falcons seem to be the wild card but
we do have an app question here from
tucker g
could the panthers still go quarterback
if lance
or fields fall what do you think mike
this is the intriguing scenario to me if
they do still go quarterback at a kind
of stand pat
play the board and if one does fall for
him pull the trigger because it will be
somewhat reminiscent now they'll have
invested a lot more draft capital of
when the seahawks signed matt flynn
way back 2012 and then still draft
russell wilson
still try to go get your guy throw as
many darts at a dartboard
as humanly possible because it's the
most valuable position in football you
saw what you had with a guy who teddy
bridgewater he's a solid
starting quarterback in the nfl you like
there are he's one of the top 25 to 32
starting quarterbacks in the league
but it's not good enough when you're
that guy so when you're towards the
bottom end of that you have to have a
perfect roster around them to win
so take as many shots as you possibly
can i'm all for that
conor let me jump in really quick if sam
is their guy
and it sounds like there were a few
other teams interested in sam the niners
being one
but if sam is the guy for carolina where
do you think they turn their attentions
to at eight
if the board plays out i think it has to
probably be the offensive line now the
corner class is really good at the
top and that's a need for them even
after the recent signing of bouillee
they made but
when you look at it you know you brought
back taylor mountain on a franchise tag
deal a really good right tackle you
still have questions at left tackle you
could still use a guard i don't really
i'm not really over the moon with
signing pat elf line and saying that so
for me at eight it's either gotta be
penne sewell or rashaan slater if you're
gonna go in that direction and i think
both of those guys could play guard if
you ask them to but in that scenario
they're stepping in and playing a left
tackle and probably playing left tackle
at a high level so it's a great question
left go if they really do commit to sam
and they're completely moved away from
taking a quarterback
and they don't move out of that pick
it's a weird pick too you have to
question if teams would
come up into that spot well the no
brainer offensive line picks one of them
at least should be on the board right
there for the taking
joey cargo commenting sam darnold will
take us to the promised land hashtag
keep pounding
for sam and for you i hope so that's a
little bit yet to be seen
renner is it 100 locked that zach
wilson's going to the jets in your mind
i'd say it's 100 like he goes two now
okay well the jets move
uh i doubt it at this point but yeah i
think it's 100
as it gets to that he's gonna go number
two overall
connor you agree yeah i absolutely agree
and
i kind of want to throw in a question
here because mike was the first person
that i saw really mention
the idea of zack wilson as a potential
first rounder and i believe that was
back in september when he had only
played a couple games and
i just kind of want to ask mike you know
when you're the first person leading
that charge
what was it that jumped out to you so
initially about
zack wilson early in the fall when i
don't even think he was on anyone's
radar as a round two pick at the time
it was just that arm and the way he
slings it
and from the body positions he can throw
with is just it's different it's
different from trevor lawrence it's
different from
justin fields mac jones even the guys
hyper talented in this draft class
the way he's able to just manipulate
that ball with just his upper half
doesn't need his lower half to be set
doesn't need to be
flat footed in the pocket standing still
he can get the ball where it needs to go
down the football field and i think that
was the biggest thing to me is like
that's what everyone's looking for
people have said them a homes comp and
that's a little too high for me but that
the things that mahomes does in that
vein
everyone the nfl wants nowadays and so
that's what he brings to the table and
that's why i said i think he's pretty
comfortably qb2 behind
trevor lawrence you mentioned justin
fields which is a perfect segue
into our most debated prospect
breakdowns running you brought us five
names that you're seeing people on
either side pretty passionately
i'm going to mention these guys i want
to know
why are they being hotly debated and
which side are you on
runner let's start with justin fields
why is there a debate and which side are
you on
with justin fields i can see why there's
a debate and why you would be low on him
the
northwestern game this past year not
great the indiana game this past year he
showed issues in terms of being able to
read the blitz being able to get the
ball out of his hands
quickly and being able to kind of
operate within the timing of that
offense
now you're talking about a guy though
who has immense physical talent
four four forty i mean he is the most
per
charting accurate quarterback in this
draft class he was the third highest
rated recruit by 247 sports at the
quarterback position
in the 20 years that they've been doing
this like this guy is talent
for days right behind trevor lawrence in
terms of the hype of him coming out
i i think he's just being over thought
because of those issues
those things easily correctable at the
nfl level and a lot of them have to do
with ohio state's offense
and the downfield passing concepts that
they run to where
i think it's a lot of smoke at the end
of the day and he still ends up going
highway
what do you think connor i'm right there
with him i
honestly i think the problem for me is
you can point out holes in justin fields
his game
like you can with every quarterback we
could sit here and do that with trevor
lawrence as well but when you talk about
the
physical talent and what we've already
seen on the film
it just really puzzles me that someone
like mac jones who's not a bad player
but still can be drafted over a player
like justin fields we've gotten to the
point where
a lot of people are overthinking him and
for me he's a lock as quarterback three
he's a lock as a top five quarterback
prospect he has all the physical
ability and work ethic as much as people
like to say different things but also
the work ethic to develop into a
franchise quarterback so i'm very high
on justin fields and
if he slid out of the top five picks of
this draft somebody made a huge mistake
atl sports joe commenting fields is the
best quarterback from this class no
doubt if atlanta were to pull the
trigger at four him being a georgia
native and this is the transition piece
that would be quite interesting we got
an app comment for our next
debated prospect it comes in from jason
tatum fan zero
thoughts on rashad bateman i've seen
some scouting sites having top 20
such as pff and others think he's a
mid-round
pick so renner i i would assume you're
the one that has them as a top 20 guy
yes yes and i can see why you would be
low on him he is not a
toolsy sort of prospect he's not a 4-3
guy he's not
super big rocked up he's not this ultra
twitchy wide receiver
uh go up and get it sort of physical but
you think about why guys fail at the
wide receiver position in the nfl
it's because either they can't get off
the line of scrimmage they can't
get in and out of their brakes as a
route runner and they can't deal with
physical corners we've seen rashad
bateman do
all of those things at a super high
level at minnesota and as a true
sophomore back on the outside when he
led
college football in terms of yards per
route so those are the reasons why guys
they don't fail because they have
middling physical tools a lot of guys
michael thomas deandre hopkins came out
and did not have incredible physical
tools but then dominate at the nfl level
i think that's a similar way i feel
about rashad bateman
yeah i mean i'm right there with you
when you look at bateman he's my number
14 overall prospect and a lot of people
don't think he's going to be drafted in
the first round but the floor is so high
i see
a play style that is kind of a blend of
a little bit of what keenan allen does
best and a little bit the old school one
stevie johnson did best and
he just wins off the line of scrimmage a
really good route runner and
he's fearless in traffic he has no
problem going across the middle of the
field he tracks the ball really well
outside the hashes with bateman it would
just surprise me if on
you know when he comes in he's not at
least an average target right away that
can mold into
a high-volume reliable target in the
intermediate game i like him a lot
he's a clear-cut number four wide
receiver for me and you know i've said
this to mike i said it on my show with
two-for-one drafts that
i look at him and think he's closer to
the devante smith conversation those top
wide receivers conversation
than he is to the back end tier where
you get into
whether it's rondelle mork darius tony
terrace marshall who i really really
like as well
i think bateman has been very very much
overlooked
all right let's go from quarterback and
wide receiver to the offensive line i
have seen this in years past eric
flowers comes to mind offensive linemen
that are just debated
and you don't know whether the technique
or the talent is going to carry through
we're going to stanford they've had a
lot of big guys over the years
walker litter excuse me walker little
mike renner uh why is there a debate and
where do you stand
reason why there's debate's obvious he's
played one game in the last two years
declined a senior bowl invite opted out
this past year because of kovid
that's a difficult evaluation when you
really haven't seen the guy since 2018
when he was a true sophomore but you go
back and evaluate what he did as a true
sophomore
and it was right up there with what
tristan wurtz was doing
andrew thomas was doing mikhail bechten
the guys in that impeccable tackle draft
class at the top there
some people thought of him as offensive
tackle one heading into that 2019 season
and as a recruit he was right up there
with him as well has all the physical
tools
and it's just we never got to see the
progression from him but on the
offensive line
it's are you willing to put in the work
do you have these sort of coordination
and other things to get to that level
and i from all accounts whether it's
david shaw
other people he's worked with he has
those things we just never got to see
that next step and so that's why i
i'm pretty high on him because i think
he has been putting into work his pro
day
was exceptional and it showed he had
definitely been putting in the work over
those past
year and a half not having played
football at that point
it's difficult for me to not keep him in
that sort of similar conversation with
like i said those guys we saw
in the top 12 15 picks last year in the
tackle class
i mean there's reasons to be scared
absolutely when you look at them the
size is great the athleticism is great
and mike is right you go back to 2018
there's some games
a lot of games where he wasn't beaten
pass bro and of course he had his tough
moments against teams like notre dame or
utah whoever it may be but he was a
young player so
the traits were there but it's hard for
me to justify taking him in the top 50
or even the top 75 when
he's played one game in the last two
years the anchor strength was never
there he got pushed back into the pocket
a lot but you do like this the
athleticism
in the run game the athleticism to be
coached up in pass bro
you just can't teach that size and
length and those feet at that size which
is something that
we've really liked about the top tackles
over the last two years i just think
it's a tough situation for him in a
really really good tackle class
to come in for a team to say hey we're
going to take this guy in the top 50
because their teams are going to want
players that can play right away
and we just have no proof of that right
now with walker little it almost feels
like he might need a redshirt ear so
it's one of those hey the traits are all
there we can draft and stash him
but how high are you willing to do that
i couldn't do it in the first two rounds
with him
part of the reason why i love this crash
course is i am learning about all these
guys
to be very honest with you for the first
time i've been in nba
ville for the last few months so renner
i see this name jamar
johnson a safety from indiana i know
nothing paint me the picture of this
prospect
and why he's being debated
he's being debated for another guy who's
not played a ton of football he was
indiana slot quarterback as a true
sophomore in 2019
moved to safety this past year but
obviously the big ten didn't play a full
schedule
didn't get to see a ton of them but he
continually made plays
on the football in coverage that you
don't really necessarily
expect a safety to make the two picks
against justin fields
in that ohio state game and you've seen
it from a number of different alignments
is the biggest thing for me that is what
you want at the nfl level the guy who
can go drop down and play in the slot
play deep middle safety play too high
whatever you want you saw him already
make plays on the football end
and you can't say that a lot about about
a lot of safety prospects in this class
and so that coverage versatility
despite it only being on like i said
about a season and a half's worth of
games
to me is exceptional and that's why he's
a top five
safety on the pff board yeah i'm with
you all the way when you look at him and
he was a late find for me somebody that
turned on the film later in the process
and went wow you know he only got on the
field mostly because of
injuries and the role that he did rather
than being a role player a full-time
player now
in coverage the range is tremendous and
it is sidelined to sideline you can ask
him to play single high like you said he
could sit in a cover or two shell he
could play in the slot
he's a little bit of a lunger as a
tackler so that's what question teams
are going to have in terms of that last
line of defense but in a league that
needs
match-up players that have a ton of
different range and coverage skills
he fits the bill he looks like a round
two pick to me all the way with those
ball skills i mean
coming away with multiple interceptions
against justin fields is probably what
you know
shined a light on him is this kind of
prospect and there's so much to be
excited about with the level of athlete
he is and the coverage
instincts he has he can be an impact
player from day one on the back end for
a team
love this questionnaire from larry
hodges do you create your own opinions
on the players
or do they tell you what to say what i
love about this question larry is
i don't know who the they is this is one
of my favorite things about
draft process is that they believe that
there's this
draft establishment that tells human
beings what to think
and i'm just going to speak for connor
and mike right now
all they have is their opinions and
their research and all of the work that
they do
and if they start taking the opinions of
other people they're less valuable so
larry it's an interesting question
i'm just telling you there's no they
like connor and renner are carrying the
show right now
because nobody knows half of what these
dudes know
i almost cursed but i'm not going to
curse last name that renner brought us
was jason and i think it's away the penn
state
hedge rusher that connor that connor
introduced me to last week that is a
physical
specimen renner what is the debate on
this guy and where do you stand
yeah physical specimen is an
understatement he had the single bro
i think i've ever seen in terms of just
all-around numbers for defensive end
prospect ran a sub 4-4
had a 11 foot two bra jump the guy his
explosiveness
personified but he didn't have a stack
last year why didn't he have a sack last
year is this kind of why everyone's
all over the map on this guy he is not a
polished product by any means he only
starts started
playing football in 2016. the guy is new
to the game was a basketball player
before that
but the length the size the
explosiveness the cornering ability
it's all there all there as much as you
know it was there for miles garrett it's
just the polish
is not there and like i said with him
being so new to the game
i'll take that chance it might not
happen year one might not happen year
two
but your high end what you could get is
miles geared it could be that top five
guy in the nfl
because that's not the case with every
edge defender in this draft class for
every other fan that comes out
yeah i mean the athletic profile is
unlike really anything we've seen before
across the board
even the three cone around a six eight
four three cone i mean for a player like
this at his size to move the way he does
it's just special and what i like about
him while you develop the pass rush plan
with him because it's very very raw like
renner said
he's somebody out of new jersey that
really started playing football late in
high school
he's a hustle run defender whether it's
from the back side whether it's setting
the edge on his side
he really does understand how to hustle
against the run so you like the floor
there now
i couldn't i don't think i could take
him in round one it's a tough sell for
me he really is a ball of clay that
you're going to need coaches
to develop him over time and you're
going to have to be patient with him and
a lot of round one pass rushers
are thrown on the field and they're
asked hey can you be this eight sack guy
right away for us
i don't think o'way is going to be that
as a rookie but in year two or three and
a lot of people said these things
about the neil hunter a player that i
was low on at the time and look how he
turned out i mean one of the best pass
rushers went healthy
in the league so away is a top 40
prospect for me i could see him sneaking
into round one because that athleticism
is just off the charts there were five
and a half sacks the year before that so
there are times he does finish
but i think the question is can you get
him to be
not just an average pass rusher right
now that's an athlete but an actual
polished one that can be that 8 to ten
sack guy down the stretch
undoubtedly it will be enticing to
coaches that go oh
i'll be the one to get the most out of
him but the problem is is
we probably have less qualified coaches
to develop players than we do have
players that need to be developed
if you want to be honest about the nfl
right now the vikings were the perfect
place for daniel hunter and he has
exploded
uh we see this all the time where there
is a debated prospect
usually it's because of an athletic
profile that there's a little bit of a
reach
and j84 wants to know who is going to be
the john ross the darius hayward bay who
is the most debated prospect
who will be the biggest reach on draft
night
and if we can i'd like to stay to night
one that first round
renner who do you think is going to be
that big reach in the first round
that one's tough because i do think in
the top 10 or so picks
there are i am a fan of a lot of those
guys who will probably
end up going there i think there's a
clear tier of blue chip guys
but i think one guy who could sneak into
the first round that just to me would be
a reach
would be jamming davis the kentucky
linebacker
437 as pro day freaky athletic skills
but you've really seen no
sort of play making ability and coverage
there's spot drop zoning at kentucky
like he is a
raw linebacker and he's already a
redshirt junior coming out only one year
as a starter
shouldn't necessarily be that raw after
four years in college so
if you're drafting that guy in the first
round you might be getting an okay run
defender i'm just not sure that
speed and elite athleticism is going to
be your coverage back or right out the
gate
renter what would your reaction be if
gregory rousseau ends up going round one
that would be a reach to me i would be
on board with that yeah
yeah it's gonna be really interesting to
see how the tape versus the athletic
profile and not playing this year lines
up that's the one i have my eyes on and
of course
we'll get a lot of different reactions
to mac jones no matter what
oh uh the the memes that are gonna be
made for mac jones when he goes three
i know that conor i don't i still think
connor's holding out
a shred of doubt that that's going to
happen uh mike i want to get uh just
some pff questions and
conor if you have any before we send
them off please jump in
what are people missing that you've been
able to detect with analytics mike over
these last few years
that you have found very valuable
that's a good question i i think one of
the biggest things
is actual performance uh
along the offensive and defensive lines
like that
yes it's the traits and tools matter but
also
it's got to be a combination of the two
you have to
basically like you have to have a floor
at those positions you can't just
take completely raw clay and that's kind
of why i say i'm still a fan of always
because he's still graded out well
as a pass rusher despite those sacks so
the guys you really can't take a guy
who's completely
inept completely unable to rush the
passer to do anything at the college
level along the
offensive defensive line where it's
still kind of a skill position
and turn them into quality nfl players
we just haven't seen it
over our seven years of grading
the other question i had for mike was
who is the best example of a player
that analytics showed you that the draft
community was
absolutely sleeping on us there one that
jumps to your mind right away
yeah i think trey flowers is the guy who
his performance and the way he played
the
position of defensive end at arkansas
coming out back in 2015
was elite was as good as it gets in
college football and
yeah he didn't have the physical profile
again that teams are looking for
but when you are that dominant a player
where at a position where it's a skill
position and you go one on one a lot
along the defensive line the offensive
line
when you can beat a guy sometimes it's
not always about
the physical tools some guys just have
that high level of skill so skill is
still a thing
that is very important and is something
that not everybody
can necessarily develop to that same
high end i go back to
kind of the cross sport example you'll
like this one let's go about stephen
curry
seven curry was shooting the way he did
when he was in sixth grade you can't
teach a guy to shoot like steph and
curry you can get them
up a little bit but you're not going to
be able to get to that super high end
in the skill perspective not everyone
can i got one last app comment question
for you renner
this one comes from tropics hawaii who
is a player on your board that is way
higher
slash lower compared to your colleagues
so this always happens every draft
there's one or two players that you get
defined by with your analysis who is
that for you this season
i think the one we're highest on is
christian barmore the alabama defensive
tackle everyone's saying it's a weak
tackle class
and i do think it is but he's a top 15
player on the pff draft board
i think he's just as good as derek brown
and javon kinlaw were last year as
prospects and he's actually
a year younger he's coming out as a
redshirt sophomore and those guys were
seniors
coming out so i'd say he's the one where
the highest and if you just flip on
the playoff he was the single most
impactful player outside of devonta
smith
in those games so i'd say he's the one
we're highest on the one we're probably
lowest on
compared to the rest of the draft
community as maybe jalen mayfield the
michigan offensive tackle
and it comes back to that level of
performance he was just getting beaten
in pass protection a lot
at the college level and yeah there is
some development a guy is young but
when you're not even meeting that basic
threshold of skill
at the college level i i don't see that
necessarily changing to him ever being
this high level pass protector in the
nfl
mike thank you so much for your time we
appreciate here
get me ready for the nfl draft you can
check him out
as always pff does great job mike thanks
so much for joining us man
for sure fellas thanks for having me on
have a good one
all right connor i got some questions
and some comments in here before we get
uh to your most debated prospect
breakdowns the ones that you provided
for us
uh first of all jja326
uh in talking about mac jones says he's
not
going three dude shut the f up
uh jj a i'll make that bet with you
it's not one that you want it's not one
that you
think um but i'll make that bet with you
i'll put a nice
nice cold 20 on there that if it doesn't
happen
you can find me i'm not going to find
you
but you can find me if that doesn't
happen the other one that i was going to
read here conor was evan o'brien
who wrote lefko isn't an expert on
anything to that i say
it's not what your mama said all right
let's get back to the show
most debated prospect breakdowns i'm not
an expert
literally the premise of this show evan
o'brien is that i'm asking conor and
people to teach me things
so that you can learn through osmosis
but thanks for the hate in the comments
section
it's gonna fuel me to become better and
bigger than ever before
connor rogers you mentioned gregory
rousseau miami edge
why is there a debate about this guy
what side are you on
and where would you like to see him end
up so
i think i'm a little lower left go i
think the nfl probably looks at him as
this top 40 prospect a dominant
sophomore
year on tape he's almost six foot seven
266 pounds
i compared him to carlos dunlap so you
see that length along the edge and
just huge hand 11 inch hands 34 and
three quarter arms i mean he's a giant
pass rusher
with great length but just not an
explosive player and you could see that
30 inch vertical should not surprise
anyone there when you talk about the get
off the snap
it's just not good enough it's not where
it needs to be right now but he can win
with the length
so much right now with swim move or
whether a rip move
where he's still a productive player but
i just don't think he's the level of
athlete on top of being a question of
where are you going to play him because
a lot of his best
wins in that great year for miami he was
lined up inside whether it was shade
nose or three tech so is he a true edge
player at the next level
i have no problem a team taking him in
the second round i think the colts
they're picking at 54 in the second
round would be a really nice landing
spot they've taken their swings for pass
rushers over the year i think when you
look at him and deforest buckner over
there you're talking about two players
that would just give a lot of problems
in terms of kind of the length that they
have as pass rushers
and then you're not expecting him it
goes back to my argument with jason oa
you're not putting him on the field as a
first rounder and saying you better get
home for us or else our
cover our corners and safeties are in
big big trouble there's just too much
pressure on him
he didn't get to play this year he's a
really hard worker everybody loves his
high character
and those raw traits but just a limited
athlete that is a little raw at the
moment right now and that would be
really really tough sell in the first
round
connor garrett greenlee comments
rousseau is marcus davenport 2.0
thoughts i mean yeah that's not crazy at
all when you look at it you're talking
about another player that
won with length now davenport did it at
lower level competition while rousseau i
mean
he beat up on a really bad fsu offensive
line that you could see
here and he really whooped up on duke as
well
so i think when you look at it everybody
knew davenport
was a reach for what they paid to go up
and get him in that draft especially in
the first round i thought he that year
was
a nice day to developmental pass rusher
and that's exactly what rousseau is as
well so
i actually like that as a situation
comparison as well by garrett
all right next name that you gave to us
was another edge rusher out of a team
that you just saw rousseau tatten up
duke chris rumpf ii break it down for me
yeah an exciting player and a totally
different player a smaller pass rusher
he's going to come in around 235 pounds
really explosive off the edge which you
know rousseau was not but rousseau has
much better size than this guy so
rump is going to be a situational player
left going even
duke rotated him if you're wondering how
they viewed him so
i like him as a stand-up situational
pass rusher with a really really good
get off
and a good outside speed rush and i
think for round three the end of round
three for the buffalo bills
they're a team that can use a little bit
more juice off of the edge and they've
done a nice job drafting over these
years
once again he's not going to be this
player that you need to be a three down
guy but the bills on those third and
longs
you know they're probably going to run
into a guy named patrick mahomes again
in big games
they need to stack that front four or
whatever they want to do even if they
want to do a front five
to get home they need guys that could
just pin their ears back and go and
right now
that's what rump is yeah they tried to
get aj
nessa last year he was more of an
all-around and didn't really give them
that
third down pressure that they were maybe
hoping for i saw people asking for this
guy to be talked about what do you know
conor's bringing him up
oklahoma state running back chuba
hubbard
all-time name what kind of a player is
he conor why is there a debate
a really good one and it's a shame that
he's getting no love in this trap you
know he had a phenomenal 2019
season and then he was hurt in 2020 he's
a
very very explosive runner and he's got
that
track speed he's got really good bursts
to get to the outside he can make you
miss
he's got some work to do in pass
protection and he's just an
okay pass catcher at the moment but as a
pure
runner especially in an outside zone
scheme
he's a home run threat left though he
really is he's got good long sweet i
don't care what the 40 is i know it
wasn't in
the four or threes but it was sub four
five he's got a good
upright strong muscled up build i think
the 49ers in round four this would be a
steal and i know they have raheem
mostert i know they have jeff wilson
but they love having that big stable of
backs that can be
the future and juba hubbard for me is my
running back five
in this draft and i see people leaving
him out of the top tens of running backs
so
i think they're focusing on being
prisoners of the moment right they're
not realizing
how good he was in 2019 when he was
healthy which is really important
at the running back position if he had
declared after that year
i think he easily goes in the second
round so the fact that he's probably
coming off the board in the fourth round
this year
that would be a steal and a perfect
scheme fit for the 49ers
okay so if that's gonna be their perfect
fit in the fourth round
can i get the 49ers dream draft uh one
two three and four how would it go
well we know about the big trade up to
number three and everybody is sitting
here going mac jones
this mac jones that i'm still riding out
hope and this is my dream draft not
anyone else's so i'm taking trey lance
third overall i think he's a much better
fit
i think the upside is ginormous it's way
bigger than what mac jones will give you
and now it brings a running element to
kyle shanahan's offense so trey lance
third overall if you really believe
coming out of the fcs he needs to sit
you got jimmy g there that's okay round
two if he got to melifon wu
really that perfect cover three kind of
corner he
reminds me of a little bit more athletic
version of a kellow witherspoon who they
just lost in free agency so now you
replace him
with melathon with incredible clicking
close coming downhill i once again i
like his size and speed combination
and ability to stay in the hip pocket or
receivers and play the ball so
round three for me this is their
compensatory selections this is a very
late pick
this would be jalen darden here the wide
receiver out of north texas
and you talk about speed in this offense
we know what they have at outside
receivers so far
they lost kendrick bourne in free agency
darden is somebody that just constantly
gets open
i think he'd be perfect for the slot
with them you can get him involved on
jet sweeps if you want but he's just
always open he could track the default
now you've added speed at the skill
spots with jalen darden
and chuba hubbard you plugged a serious
hole right now at
corner and then you have your
quarterback franchise superstar
quarterback of the future in trey lance
if this doesn't excite you as a 49ers
fan i'm sorry but i think this would be
the dream draft scenario
for them talking about chuba there a
murray24 asked when did running a 4-4
become slow i don't remember what
nfl player was but they just put it out
everybody's running in the four threes
right now so yes
four fours four fives are fast but in a
year where it's seemingly
all pro day no laser it sure seems like
there's a whole lot of four twos and
four
three this is going to go down as like
the fastest class ever
because of all am i am i crazy or conor
am i kind of accurate
no you and that comment are preaching to
the choir and there's this little thing
called game tape speed left go if you
turn it on from 2019 shuba hubbard has a
ton of big breakaway runs
and that is going to translate at the
next level and like i said there's also
a lot of different times out there when
he initially ran
people said it was 436 and it gets
posted at 446.
there's no consistent process here in
place in my opinion with a lot of
different scouts times
but i've watched chuba hubbard play
football he's fast
all right the the fourth name that you
brought to us an offensive lineman from
tennessee
trey smith what's the debate here
the debate is a couple of different
things and number one he's just a
powerhouse right he's
a incredible drive blocker if he gets
you in a phone booth
he gets his hands on you you're going
into the stands that's where you're
going now what people have
questions is that overall movement
ability and pass protection
i really don't have that when he was a
freshman let go he started some games
that left
tackle so i think when you look at it
the number one question teams have
because this was a problem for him in
college
was the blood clot issue that sidelined
him one
season now if that's behind him and you
believe he can stay healthy
he's a mauler he fits everything that
joe judge would want on his team the
identity of his football team so
trey smith is just looking for work
right there he's a powerhouse
he loves to play the game he loves to
bury people when you watch tennessee
versus alabama
he's somebody that shows up and drives
people backwards so it's not even a
level of competition thing
he beats up on everyone i think trey
smith would just be this perfect round
three pick for the new york giants that
they still have some questions on the
offensive line we're gonna see in his
last year on his contract what will
hernandez does
shane lemieux i know they have they're
hoping for but they like competition
there so
round three for trey smith the giants i
think he'd be their answer at guard
and really get that run game going with
saquon barkley
yeah losing kevin zeitler was a big loss
for the giants so they're gonna have to
plug somebody in there let's play the
dream draft game
one more time if trey smith is your
third round dream pick
for the giants what's one and two so we
got some help on the offensive line in
round three a guy that i think is a plug
and play starter at a high level let's
go round one devonte smith i think he's
the receiver
out of chase and waddle and obviously
kyle pitts is a tight end but more of a
pass catching weapon
i think smith is the guy that might see
a tumble now eleven's not a bad tumble
i know the giants have other needs here
but give daniel jones a shot now you
have devonte smith you have kenny
golliday
you have sterling shepherd darius
slayton saquon barkley in the backfield
the offensive line hopefully can play at
a higher level
i know it's a laughable pro bowl but
evan ingram did make the pro bowl i'm
not crazy about them but
a plethora of pass catching options here
for daniel jones
and davonte smith no one is more pro
ready than him round two they need edge
help they need it badly and joe trion
did not play this year
but from what i saw for a young starter
in 2019
he is a powerful guy on the edge
powerful hands
can convert speed to power to push
tackles back into the pocket
sets the edge very very well they're a
team that joe judge is not going to want
anyone running on them
try on next to leonard williams gives
them a lot of strength
up front so for the giants you get a
little bit of everything there you feel
much better about your offense and
helping out your young quarterback
but you've got to get somebody on the
outside that can rush the passer as well
all right so that is your dream draft
for the new
york football giants we are getting
ready for rapid fire questions i want to
be selfish
really quick i just want to name connor
who are you mocking to my eagles at 12
right now just for my own
brain i i think it's probably going to
be one of the corners if a receiver
doesn't fall and when i had this
conversation with you and tanabaum i
said
hey if one of jamar chase jalen waddle
kyle pitts or devante smith falls
that's who the eagles take right you're
going to go back to that wide receiver
well again this year
but you have to prepare if that doesn't
happen and i still think they can use
a corner they can capitalize on this
class we'll see who falls out of certain
or jc horn i know a lot of eagles fans
and i get it are talking about micah
parsons i don't think you need to take
linebacker there that early he's a
really good player
an effective player a great athlete he
could do a little bit of everything
but for the eagles i'd like to take one
of those top corners if a pass catcher
isn't there
thank you for doing that that helped my
brain now i know what to focus on uh we
read a comment
from garrett greenlee earlier well guess
what garrett your video comment is being
played now which means a hoodie
is coming your way let's hear what
garrett had to ask
hey guys with the edge and the
linebackers i've had to fit in my head
for a couple weeks now and i absolutely
love jeremiah wow sue corey mohit to the
raiders
and him you know being i don't wanna say
the travis kelsey uh
eliminator but him at least being able
to try and limit him over the next
couple of years i really love that and
the raiders aren't going to have to you
know limit justin herbert and patrick my
homes over the next decade
and i just want to know your thoughts on
a location fit there whether you like it
hate it or if that's even a possibility
they have in the first round thanks love
the show
i mean i love it it's a good call now i
think my biggest question is
is j they've had a lot of movement on
the offensive line this offseason left
go
are they going to be looking to
capitalize on a really good class where
are they picking in the top 20 picks
there
before you get a run right i mean you
look at it there
the board is going to move quickly in
the back end of this first round the
raiders are sitting there at 17.
you got washington at 19 the bears at 20
the colts at 21 the titans at 22 the
jets at 23.
the steelers at 24. all of those teams
could take offensive linemen so the
raiders are going to have to sit there
and have a tough question and go
do we take someone like tevin jenkins
right now before we watch
all the players we like come off the
board a couple picks after us
but in terms of the player and the fit i
mean it's great he's a do-it-all player
he play he's a linebacker that covered
out in the slot and had no problem doing
it so the range is phenomenal sideline
to sideline
running the seam you talk about the
tight ends in that division you look at
the running backs in that division the
big wide receivers in the red zone
i really really like the fit and this is
a unpredictable drafting team
the raiders so you have to keep all
scenarios on your mind
it's not crazy at all that's just a
little note for everybody if you submit
videos in the nfl draft community and we
play it
you are getting a hoodie garrett
congrats on making the big show
all right rapid fire question jonathan
heath
who will the washington football team
pick in the first round
connor what are you thinking well i
talked about offensive line earlier
right when you look at it they're at 19.
they could use another offensive tackle
they could use a linebacker i know they
need a slot corner they'll worry about
that
later i think it has to be this
offensive line class right you saw
enough from your young running back last
year in antonio gibson i don't think you
take a round one running back here so
we know sewell and slater are going to
be gone i like christian darasaw here
lefko i think his tape
was phenomenal i think he warrants being
a top 15 pick although everything i'm
hearing is that
he will not go in the top 15. so that's
a little bit of a bonus for washington
sitting there
they get a plug and play tackle that
fits the demeanor of the team because
he's a bully in the run game
he dramatically improved over as a
three-year starter in pass protection
where he was
lights out this year so darasaw would be
my dream pick
if he can make it to that spot all right
azor ahai
atl i just saw this morning jerry jones
is apparently obsessed with kyle pitts
but the question is how high should
pitts go
not how high will he go is he really a
once in a generation prospect connor
i mean you're talking to somebody that
thinks he shouldn't be the top
skill guy drafted in the draft and i
love him he's a great tight end
compared him to darren waller he's a red
zone weapon
he has incred the largest wingspan ever
recorded for a tight end
so that's different the speed is really
really good
but let go jamar chase is one of the
best wide receivers i've ever evaluated
jamar
chase should be the top pass catcher
taken you could sell me
because of his speed that jaylen waddle
would be
a more impactful player than kyle pitts
i know a lot of people won't agree with
this and i understand and they'll
probably bring about a lot of hateful
comments because
they've been sold that kyle pitts is
unlike anything we've ever seen before
but if you're saying that
that means you think he's going to be
either rob gronkowski or travis kelsey
that's really really lofty and maybe he
will be
depending on his landing spot but kyle
pitts to me
is a top 12 pick not a top five pick and
i know that
might seem nitpicking but those are huge
decisions when you're talking about the
top five of the draft versus the top 12
the 15 of the draft
especially because gronk and travis
kelsey are phenomenal blockers and from
one of our past shows kyle pitts is just
not there yet
uh next app question at 24 should the
steelers take the best running back or
offensive lineman available
or should they trade up from rip speedy
they should take the offensive lineman
that the best one available now the
question is i just raised the point of
all the teams picking ahead of you
do you have to move up it's not
something that you necessarily want to
do it's something you might have to do
now it wouldn't shock me if they take a
nazi harris not at all with the identity
and how they make up their football
teams i'm not going to take a running
back in round one if i'm the steelers i
got to keep big ben upright
the core of your run game has to be
built on the offensive line
there's enough talented running backs
you can get in rounds two three or four
whatever it may be
so i look at it and just wonder who's
gonna fall if things don't go my way
christian darasaw's already gone
how about tevin jenkins how about alex
leatherwood liam eichenberg
those are players that i can get behind
elijah vera tucker is my top
guard although some people do think he
can play tackle so that's another name
as well
but those guys could not make it to 24
if we get the offensive line run we
think we're in for
all right app question here from rip
melo what round is asante samuel
jr going in connor i'm gonna say the top
of round two
now you can make the argument that he
has some round one ability we just don't
see corners
that size aren't locks necessarily for
round one now he's a really good athlete
he's a feisty man coverage corner which
has to be valued in today's game
5 foot 10 180 pounds 441 speed now the
twitchiness
6983 cone his lateral ability
and the ability to come downhill to stop
on a dime and come downhill and play the
football
i really like it i'm just answering the
question though of what i think will
happen
i think he's more in the top 45 picks
than the top 32.
all right we got two more questions
connor who is the better running back
coming out of north carolina
from chris j yeah it's javonte williams
but it's not an easy question to answer
because michael carter absolutely is a
you could justify he should be a top 100
pick no brainer
incredible agility they're totally
different players javonte williams to me
reminds me of chris carson who people
look at that comparison they go that's
not really impressive
i mean chris carson is one of the better
runners in the nfl the last couple of
years so i think when i look at it
michael carter gives you more agility he
gives you more bursts
maybe now javonte williams i can't even
say make more make you miss javonte
williams forced the most missed tackles
out of any running back in this class so
people will like him in pass pro as well
and that's a big differentiating factor
in all of this
but the point is two running backs come
out of the same program in the same year
as top 100 selections
is really impressive all right i'm
almost
dying connor so we have one last
question power power
power throw it is
guys huge fan of your show especially
left go for your days with chris
who do you think is the best quarterback
fit for the patriots
if they trade up patriots currently
sitting
at pick number 15 from go subon 12.
go thank you bro connor what do you
think if they were to trade up into that
top eight
yeah i think it would be trey lance and
if not him then justin fields i think
they could use
a mobile quarterback that's a big-bodied
player that can sit behind cam newton
execute similar concepts push the ball
down the field now justin fields
accuracy would just be tremendous for
that offense that is going to be using
the middle of the field
a ton with the two tight ends johnny
smith and hunter
henry two guys they just gave a ton of
money so you like that with
fields now my question here is do they
get the choice
because one two three are going to be
quarterbacks and then somebody might
trade with atlanta maybe it is new
england
that they are gonna take a quarterback
at four as well assuming atlanta doesn't
sit there and just take one themselves
which i would do that if i was atlanta i
don't think they do
so new england i think you're in good
hands because i think one of those guys
will fall if you move up enough
and i think they'd both be stars in that
offense they're afforded the opportunity
to sit
we know how well coach that offensive
line is they've made a significant
effort to upgrade the pass catching
situation there which would help any
young quarterback
and i think having cam newton there is a
really really good mentor for any of
these guys in this quarterback class
the bread man 10 asked connor olefco you
guys would be a good tag team in wwe
what would be your team name look at
connor's hair it would be
hustle and flow perfect
perfect um and also i just want to say
really quick to
jay jah you think that mac jones isn't
going three
let me tell you something he's going
three and you're gonna owe me twenty
dollars
let me put this back up here hold on he
might not let go he might not
really he might not i don't know i
i have this weird theory that uh kyle
shanahan has bamboozled the insider
community
bamboozled chris sims i love that that
would make me happy
great i'm gonna be happy either way
uh thank everybody for joining us on the
br app
gridiron twitter br youtube we do this
every thursday at one o'clock
i just tap into connor's brain and i get
all of the information that i can
big shout out to mike renner from pm pff
for joining us today next week
sleepers and hidden gems give you guys
some names and some nuggets so you can
go to your friends and sound really
smart
when someone gets picked a little bit
earlier than everybody thought about
submit your questions as i mentioned
before in the nfl
draft community if it's a good video we
will play it and you'll get a hoodie
and draft weekend what is going on with
that connor what's draft weekend shows
i mean draft weekend is going to be
bananas uh we're going to be
oh that's our job yeah yeah
yes all three days live um they are
going to be
big time shows let go this might be the
last week
we can't talk about who is on the desk
with us
and there's gonna be more than just the
person that's on the desk with us that's
a part of the show so
if you watch next week uh i'm just
everyone's gonna be mind blown when we
announce our our draft
analyst team team this year team
team it's all about the team and the
avengers of the nfl draft
i love that i'll be the doctor strange
just opening portals
uh connor you killed it as always mike
renner great all of our production team
that made this possible
you are awesome to everybody watching in
the app appreciate y'all
have a great day and we'll see you guys
next week one o'clock eastern
see ya
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you